[Music]
taiwanese soldiers practicing defending
their islands against invaders
these are only drills but they are
preparing for a reason as a result of
the war in ukraine taiwan has raised its
own alert level
the tiny dongian islands are taiwanese
territory and they sit just off the
chinese mainland
china views taiwan as a renegade
province that it has a sacred duty to
reunify as they call it
in asia as in europe a young democracy
sits next door to an authoritarian giant
and taiwan too is prepared to fight hand
to hand if it comes to that
this is xiamen in china just four miles
over the water from the kin-men islands
which belong to taiwan as well
the view makes it a prize spot for
selfies
and for the taiwanese looking back
across the channel there is this giant
sign
it proclaims one country two systems
unified china the communist party's
model for how it would integrate
democratic taiwan
but on a weekend before the drills the
mood is pretty oblivious in this
potential global flashpoint
and people's opinions on taiwan capture
the ambiguity of china's position
there are hopes for peace
and threats of war
but just like between russia and ukraine
the issue is complicated by the number
of taiwanese people with connections to
china and vice versa
joey huang is taiwanese she moved to
xiamen just over a year ago
obviously now we're all looking at
what's happening in ukraine and the
horrible pictures do you worry that a
similar thing could happen
here and in taiwan if there's conflicts
between china and taiwan
first of all i don't think the
condition is the same
second
i
am very very worried about
taiwan
the relationship of taiwan and mainland
but there is no denying the overt
pressure china is putting on taiwan
it regularly flies planes into the
island's air defense identification zone
and it has never renounced the use of
force if peaceful methods fail
for the foreign policy establishment
that studies this issue ukraine has
already changed the calculation not for
china but for taiwan
war between china and taiwan is
certainly not imminent nor is it
inevitable
but we have learned over these last
weeks how quickly bustling cities can be
turned into wastelands how quickly
residents can become refugees those
lessons apply here too tom cheshire sky
news xiamen